[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance you may not know the
difference between the Pittsburgh
Penguins and the Penguins from Batman
and the only thing Donald Trump may know
about them is that they play a sport
where one of the positions is called
right wing but at this moment they are
or nearly are the centerpieces in the
lack of culture war between America's
would-be dictator and those of us who
you know like democracy the Penguins
have mastered this continents most
grueling and demanding sports season and
have won the greatest trophy in sports
the Stanley Cup in back-to-back years
but right now they have in fact become
the Pittsburgh political pawns
last Saturday apparently having just
learned that the basketball champion
Golden State Warriors had refused to go
to the inevitably painful but by now
traditional White House Championship
photo-op Trump pretended he was refusing
to see them exactly 26 hours later the
Penguins tweeted out a link to a
statement about their planned visit to
the White House to what used to be the
symbol of American democracy until Trump
came along the Pittsburgh Penguins
respect the institution of the office of
the president and the long tradition of
championship teams visiting the White
House we attended White House ceremonies
after previous championships touring the
historic building and visiting briefly
with President George HW Bush and Barack
Obama and have accepted an invitation to
attend again this year any agreement or
disagreement with the president's
politics policies or agenda can be
expressed in other ways however we very
much respect the rights of other
individuals and groups to express
themselves as they see fit as an ardent
hockey fan whose mother saw the New York
Rangers win a game in the Stanley Cup
final of 1940 and who laments the sports
relative obscurity here and who has for
50 years
found among hockey people some of the
most naturally understanding and
inclusive and empathetic of all people I
know what the Penguins were trying to do
here among other things they might be
going to the White House as soon as
October 11th so they were trying to get
out in front of trouble but anybody with
a little more sophistication could have
told them what would necessarily happen
next
Trump panicking over the instantaneous
repudiation
his National Football League boycott
idea in at least two cases by his
buddies Bob Kraft and Schad Kahn NFL
owners who had reportedly donated
millions to his inauguration committee
Trump looking for a fight after the
warriors humiliated him picked up the
Penguins sweet little gesture of a note
and began to hit people over the head
with it pleased to inform that the
champion Pittsburgh Penguins of the NHL
will be joining me at the White House
for ceremony great team first of all
it's pleased with addy [ __ ] secondly
the Penguins are now Trump's political
pawns they're nice little apolitical
excuse us most of us are Canadian any
agreement or disagreement with the
president's politics policies or agenda
can be expressed in other ways statement
that has been erased there are now
political pawns the Pittsburgh political
pawns their trip to the White House is
now agreement not disagreement with this
president's politics policies and agenda
his hatreds are now the Penguins hatreds
his racism's are now the Penguins
racism's his lunacies are now the
Penguins lunacies but it's worse than
that
at the start of the month the National
Hockey League and its players union made
a big deal out of something new called
hockey's Declaration of Principles it is
all good stuff about ideals and
character and life skills and there's
nothing about just keep your stick on
the puck and don't get down on your luck
and then there's the last of the
principles number eight all hockey
programs should provide a safe positive
and inclusive environment for players
and families regardless of race color
religion national origin gender age
disability sexual orientation and
socioeconomic status simply put hockey
is for everyone Bravo unfortunately
Penguins Donald Trump is not for
everyone if there were ever a time you
do not want to go see this guy it's when
your entire sport has just stood up for
inclusion and against discrimination for
race color religion national origin or
anything else and the President of the
United States has just described a bunch
of African American athletes by
screaming quote get that son of a [ __ ]
off
the field right now out he's fired is
fired the Penguins are captained by
Sidney Crosby and owned by a former star
player named Mario Lemieux and the two
of them are legendary for their
leadership and neither Crosby nor
Lemieux is showing any leadership right
now nor is the National Hockey League
nor its commissioner Gary Bettman the
Penguins can't go I don't care if they
have to claim they can't find the
Stanley Cup and they will show up when
and if they locate it I don't care if
they say the coach has cancelled the
trip and demanded a 16-hour practice
instead that day
NHL coaches are always doing something
like that anyway the Pittsburgh Penguins
must now decline the white house
invitation or render hockey's new
Declaration of Principles laughingly
meaningless there's nothing in there
about athletes being used by a crazy
political figure in a desperate crisis
of his own making and being paraded out
in front of a camera like they are all
Dennis Rodman visiting Kim jong-un
there's nothing in there about
politeness and the hockey desire to
please everybody that requires you to
become political hostages or the
Pittsburgh political props or the
Pittsburgh political pawns or the
Pittsburgh PAC seized resist remove
piece